politique
bonsoir et bienvenue dans
l'hebdopolitique votre rendez-vous du
dimanche soir sur Radio sensation en
association avec tv78 épisode 220 mon
invitée ce soir et le député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines William
Martinez
[Musique]
William Martinez bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes le nouveau député de la 11e
circonscription des Yvelines est l'un
des nouveaux visages de l'Assemblée
nationale alors ancien étudiant de
l'université de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous vous avez
engagé rapidement à l'Union nationale
des étudiants de France l'UNEF vous en
devenez le président entre 2013 et 2016
c'est comme cela que vous découvrez la
scène médiatique en luttant contre la
loi travail de Manuel Valls à l'époque
après votre mandat de président de
l'Unef vous devenez ensuite membre de la
France insoumise chargée vous étiez
chargé de l'écriture et de la
coordination du plan 0 SDF de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pour la campagne
présidentielle alors en juin dernier
vous êtes élu donc député comment se
sont passés vos premiers moments que
vous me permettez de rajouter juste un
petit morceau dans cette biographie
c'est que après mon engagement étudiant
et après mes études j'ai travaillé
pendant plusieurs années dans une
association de lutte contre le
sans-abrisme voilà c'était ce qui
explique mon activité professionnel et
voilà c'est notamment pour ça que dans
le cadre de mon engagement politique qui
jusqu'à il y a jusqu'à mon élection été
bénévole c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur le sujet du sans-abrisme
et du plan zéro sans abri dont vous avez
parlé et donc vos premiers moments à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'est-ce que ça
fait d'être élu député et commencer
c'est très impressionnant c'est vraiment
impressionnant rien que que le lieu les
bâtiments quand vous rentrez à
l'Assemblée nationale au Palais Bourbon
quand vous rentrez dans l'hémicycle
c'est un lieu qui est chargé d'histoire
vous vous sentez vraiment tout petit et
j'ai envie de dire c'est une bonne chose
je trouve que ça fasse cette effet parce
que ça vous rappelle toute la
responsabilité que vous avez et la
responsabilité de porter la voix de ceux
qui vous ont élu voilà parce que quand
on arrive dans l'hémicycle c'est à dire
que avant on a fait des mois et des mois
de campagne moi j'ai fait une campagne
qui était beaucoup sur le terrain j'ai
fait beaucoup de porte à porte j'ai
beaucoup discuté avec avec les gens on
les écoute on prend des engagements
auprès d'eux sur les sujets sur lesquels
on va se battre on prend voilà les
mythique c'est ça dans l'hémicycle on se
dit maintenant il va il va pas falloir
déconner hein et il va falloir bien
défendre les gens et tenir les
engagements qu'on a pris au moment des
résultats le soir du deuxième tour
l'ensemble des observateurs politiques
annoncer une assemblée incontrôlable un
pays à la limite un gouvernable alors
quelques mois après comment juger vous
les les premiers instants de cette 16e
législature il y a une réalité c'est que
cette élection législative pour le
président de la République ça a été une
défaite je rappelle parce qu'on l'a
parfois oublié que au premier tour de
l'élection législative c'est laupes qui
arrivait en tête devant les candidats de
la majorité présidentielle voilà et
c'est au second tour notamment parce que
malheureusement beaucoup d'acteurs
politiques de la majorité présidentielle
on préférait faire élire des candidats
de l'extrême droite plutôt que les
candidats à nups c'est ça qui permet à
Emmanuel Macron d'avoir une majorité qui
maintenant n'est plus qu'une majorité
relative donc ça a été quand même un
coup de semence politique cette élection
cette élection législative et ça je
crois qu'il ne faut pas l'oublier et
toutes les tentatives de la part du
pouvoir qui reviendrait à essayer de
remettre le couvercle sur ce qui s'est
exprimé pendant ces élections
législatives à mon avis politiquement
serait quelque chose de très dangereux
parce qu'il y a de la contestation qui
s'est exprimée et il faut que le
gouvernement est maintenant la modestie
d'entendre ça et malheureusement le
l'expérience des premières semaines
montre que cette modestie je crois elle
est pas trop au rendez-vous ils veulent
faire comme ils ont fait depuis 5 ans
c'est-à-dire continuer à décider tout
seul ça je pense que ça ne fonctionnera
pas les premiers débats ont été marqués
par la loi sur le pouvoir d'achat
l'inflation avait atteint 6,1% en
juillet cet été elle concerne toute la
population mais on va s'intéresser avec
vous à la précarité étudiante c'est le
moment de la rentrée c'est en ce mois de
septembre vous vous c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez bien vous avez enchaîné
les petits boulots à l'époque de vos
études on vient de sortir d'une période
assez compliquée avec la pandémie
maintenant c'est l'inflation est-ce que
vous êtes inquiet pour la rentrée des
étudiants en ce mois de septembre moi je
suis très inquiet pour les étudiants
bien sûr mais pour toute une série de
catégories de la population qui est
confronté à cette à cette inflation faut
parfois quand on dit les chiffres comme
ça on a du mal à mesurer les
conséquences quand il y a une inflation
qui est à 6%, alors que du point de vue
des salaires et même des prestations
sociales on a soit une stagnation soit
des augmentations qui sont très loin de
l'inflation ça veut dire que les gens
perdent en pouvoir d'achat il y a des
gens qui qui étaient payés proches du
SMIC et qui se retrouvent à la rentrée
avec en fait - 6% de pouvoir d'achat
c'est-à-dire c'était dur de faire ses
courses de remplir son frigo de payer le
loyer et on perd on perd 6%. donc c'est
une des choses qui fait que je pense que
là la rentrée sociale va être très
compliqué parce que les gens sont
vraiment sont vraiment pris à la gorge
et vous avez raison de de pointer la
situation des étudiants ou ça fait
longtemps qu'il y a de la précarité dans
le milieu étudiant et là ça va ça va se
renforcer et on l'a vu pendant la crise
sanitaire vous vous souvenez c'est ces
fils d'affrent devant les distributions
alimentaires c'est avec donc des
dizaines et des dizaines d'étudiants qui
avaient besoin de
euh vous savez le montant maximum d'une
d'une bourse pour un étudiant donc qui a
ses parents qui n'ont quasiment aucun
revenu on est à peine au niveau du RSA
on est autour de 500 euros là le
maintenant je crois que le les jetons
maximum de bourse et le numéro 6 ou 7
voilà c'est 5900 € par an voilà je le
redis-moi voilà donc on se rend compte
de où on en est on explique à des jeunes
qui ont des parents qui n'ont absolument
aucune ressource donc du coup des jeunes
qui ont pas de transfert de ressources
de leur de leur famille qui doivent
vivre avec le montant d'un RSA c'est
évidemment pas évidemment pas possible
et encore là on parle de ceux qui entre
guillemets ont la chance de toucher une
bourse parce qu'on sait que une des
faiblesses de ce système de bourse c'est
que le montant des aides est calculé sur
le revenu des parents alors qu'il y a
très souvent une déconnexion entre le
revenu des parents et à quel point les
jeunes sont aidés ou pas parce que le la
vie c'est toujours plus compliqué que ça
parce que maintenant on est étudiant
jusqu'à 22 23 24 25 ans qu'on n'est pas
toujours aidé par ses parents donc il y
a toute une série de jeunes qui ne soit
rien de leurs parents et à qui le CROUS
s'explique quand même que le revenu de
leurs parents est trop élevé et donc du
coup ils ont pas le droit à une aide et
donc ça c'est les deux tiers des
étudiants qui ont pas le droit à une à
une bourse sacrée aussi des situations
de précarité qui sont qui sont
extrêmement fortes donc quand face à ça
on a un gouvernement qui n'a rien
d'autre à nous dire que on va
revaloriser les bourses en dessous de
l'inflation alors qu'on est un système
qui est dans une qui est dans une
impasse évidemment ça peut pas nous
satisfaire il faut faire autre chose
dans le programme justement de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon l'avenir en commun vous
défendez la création d'une allocation
d'autonomie de 1063 euros pour les
étudiants à l'occasion de cette rentrée
2022 lunettes donc vous étiez d'ailleurs
l'ancien président on a refait la
demande au gouvernement je vous propose
d'écouter la proposition de la
Fédération des associations générales
étudiantes la phage par la voie
d'Anne-Laure Siriex la vice-présidente
en charge des questions sociales écoutez
alors on n'est pas parfaitement en
accord avec l'allocation d'autonomie on
estime que il y a un système des bourses
qui est très intéressant et qui est
vraiment doit être
restructuré et réformé pour que ça
puisse accueillir plus de personnes
qu'on supprime aussi les échelons qu'on
peut connaître à l'heure actuelle et
qu'on du coup on est un réel une réelle
aide qui répond aux besoins de
l'étudiant en fonction de son revenu une
réforme structurelle des bourses donc
plutôt qu'une allocation d'autonomie
pourquoi selon vous la deuxième option
est préférable il y a un débat et il est
sans doute utile et important entre les
organisations étudiantes sur la façon
dont il faut réformer le système mais
franchement moi ce qui me paraît le
débat central c'est celui entre les
étudiants et la quasi-totalité de leurs
organisations qui demandent quoi qu'il
en soit une réforme du système en
profondeur qu'on appelle ça allocation
d'autonomie ou autre chose cette
exigence du côté des étudiants et de
l'autre côté un gouvernement qui est
sourd assez revendication moi c'est
quand même ça qui me frappe qui me
frappe le plus alors après ça n'empêche
pas sur le fond vous l'avez dit nous on
défend cette proposition d'allocation
d'autonomie qui répond à plusieurs
choses d'abord à l'urgence sociale que
je décrivais tout à l'heure c'est plus
possible que dans notre pays la 6e
puissance économique mondiale il y a des
étudiants qui à faire la queue pour
avoir pour bénéficier de distribution
alimentaire qui est normalement un
dispositif qui est humanitaire donc il
faut un investissement massif pour
répondre à ça on fixe un montant à 1063
euros alors peut-être certains se
demandent pourquoi le 1063 euros c'est
parce que c'est le montant du seuil de
pauvreté voilà tout simplement donc
l'idée c'est que on doit avoir personne
en dessous du seuil de pauvreté et
encore moins les étudiants d'où ce 1063
euros et l'autre idée qui est derrière
et qui est importante derrière la
location d'autonomie c'est que comme son
nom l'indique on veut mettre en
protection sociale et en autonomie la
jeunesse c'est-à-dire déconnecter la
question du revenu des parents de
l'accompagnement social et de la bourse
dont bénéficie l'étudiant parce que
comme je le disais tout à l'heure on a
plein de situations où en fait l'aide
dont bénéficie d'étudiant et pas corrélé
aux revenus de ces de ses parents donc
là il s'agit de faire et j'en conviens
c'est une grande transformation dans
notre dans notre système de dire que
maintenant qu'on a énormément de jeunes
qui font des études des jeunes de toutes
les catégories sociales que ces études
durent pendant longtemps on peut plus
s'en sortir avec juste un système qui
complète l'aide des parents maintenant
il faut un système qui met en protection
sociale et qui rend autonome toute une
génération quand elle fait ses études et
je finis juste en disant c'est non
seulement évidemment dans l'intérêt des
jeunes qu'on protège de la précarité
mais c'est aussi j'ai même envie de dire
surtout dans l'intérêt de la société
parce qu'on a besoin de jeunes qui
soient mieux formés et mieux qualifiés
en France qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre
comme richesse que nos jeunes leur
cerveaux et les études qui vont faire
voilà comme on disait déjà dans les
années 70 on n'a pas de pétrole on a des
idées alors si on reformule un peu c'est
on n'a pas de pétrole mais on a des
jeunes qui n'attendent qu'une chose
c'est d'être qualifié pour répondre au
défi de la transition écologique etc de
tout ce qu'on a de tout ce qu'on a à
faire donc il faut mettre le paquet
là-dessus donc c'est un choix politique
et qui est partagé par pas mal
d'organisations syndicales étudiantes et
que nous effectivement à la nupette on
partage également il y a urgence à cette
allocation d'autonomie le 8 septembre le
président de la République Emmanuel
Macron a lancé le Conseil national de la
refondation ça s'est passé en
Île-de-France à Marcoussis finalement
les collectivités locales ont décidé de
participer mais pas les oppositions même
l'ancien Premier ministre Édouard
Philippe ne souhaite pas y prendre pas
écouter Bruno Le Maire au micro de
Jessie Willens le ministre de l'Économie
réitère son invitation c'était lors de
sa dernière visite ministérielle c'était
dans votre circonscription attrape la
seule chose c'est qu'on ne peut pas
dialoguer tout seul
et je regrette profondément l'attitude
de l'opposition lorsque elle fuit le
débat
s'opposer ce n'est pas faire la
politique de la chaise vide s'opposer
c'est pas refuser de dialoguer avec le
président de la République dans le
Conseil national de la refondation je
regrette que le président du Sénat ne
participe pas à ce conseil national de
la refondation qui me semble une
initiative gaulliste posé en dehors du
cadre politique dans un cadre qui doit
être le plus serein possible avec tous
les acteurs c'est à dire les
représentants syndicaux des
représentants patronaux avec des acteurs
de la société civile avec le Conseil
économique et social avec des
scientifiques poser des grands sujets
que la France doit devoir affronter dans
les prochaines décennies le climat
le vieillissement de la population la
réindustrialisation de la France tout ça
ça mérite qu'on débat de sereinement
qu'est-ce que ça coûte de bien discuter
qu'est-ce que ça coûte de venir
dialoguer qu'est-ce que ça coûte de
faire part de ses convictions même si
nous ne sommes pas d'accord donc je
j'appelle à nouveau l'opposition tous
ceux qui ont fermé la porte tous ceux
qui font la politique de la chaise vide
à participer au dialogue qu'a ouvert le
président de la République dans le cas
de ce constat national de leur fondation
parce qu'il me paraît salutaire pour
sortir des débats conjoncturels parfois
épidermiques essayez d'apporter des
réponses de long terme structurées
solides au défi que la France va avoir
affronter vous fuyez le débat où il y a
Martinet non soyons sérieux je crois que
nous savons tous ce qui va se passer
avec ce conseil national de la
refondation il y aura peut-être du débat
on verra
Emmanuel Macron va peut-être écouter là
aussi on verra mais il y a une chose
dont on est sûr c'est que Emmanuel
Macron va décider tout seul quel que
soit avant le débat qui aura eu lieu
voilà parce que Emmanuel Macron il y a
une chose qui n'a pas compris c'est que
il continue cet exercice du pouvoir
solitaire c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
même après la crise sanitaire et
continue à réunir le conseil de défense
par exemple pour pouvoir prendre des
décisions dans le secret le plus le plus
absolu et donc je pense qu'il en
décalage total avec la demande de
démocratie qui existe dans le dans le
pays et je rajoute même que je pense que
cette opération de communication parce
que ce CNR c'est une opération de
communication je pense que c'est jouer
avec le feu parce que parce qu'on joue
en fait avec la j'allais dire la naïveté
même la bonne volonté des gens en leur
disant venez discuter venez on va
débattre alors que à la fin on sait que
les propositions qui seront faites ne
seront pas prises en compte et que
Emmanuel Macron l'a déjà fait il l'a
déjà fait vous vous souvenez au moment
de la mobilisation des gilets jaunes on
a eu une grande convention nationale et
moi je me souviens très bien à l'époque
déjà j'étais sur les plateaux télé je
disais c'est une arnaque Macron va
discuter mais c'est de la com il va pas
il va pas vous écouter et malgré
d'ailleurs ce que disait l'opposition ce
que disait la France insoumise parce que
les gens sont de bonne volonté il y en a
quand même plein qui sont allés qui ont
rempli les cahiers de doléances qui ont
écrit qui ont dit plein de plein de
choses qu'est-ce qui a été retenu de ça
rien du tout rien du tout et pareil
après sur la convention citoyenne pour
le climat même histoire nous en tant
qu'opposition on dit attention vous
risquez de vous faire piéger on comprend
la volonté de sur des enjeux aussi
importants que les associations etc les
citoyens tirés au sort donnent leur avis
mais vous allez voir à la fin Macron va
tout balayer c'est ce qui s'est passé
donc là voilà Macron recommence avec
cette même stratégie de communication on
fait semblant d'écouter et à la fin on
décide tout seul mais moi je dis que ça
c'est dangereux parce que c'est un
profond mépris pour les gens et on peut
les tromper une fois deux fois trois
fois mais à la fin les gens ont marre et
socialement ça devient une une
cocotte-minute et ça me paraît
extrêmement dangereux donc moi je dis
plutôt à Emmanuel Macron s'il veut du
débat il a bien raison parce qu'on a
besoin d'avoir dans le débat
démocratique ça tombe bien il y a une
Assemblée nationale qui vient d'être
élue voilà par des députés qui ont été
élus par les citoyens français et bah
menons les débats faisons les compromis
à l'intérieur de cette Assemblée
nationale alors c'est sûr que c'est plus
compliqué pour lui parce qu'elle
Assemblée nationale le président peut
pas arriver en disant j'ai écouté les
débats mais voilà j'ai décidé ça se
passe comme ça mais ouais mais c'est le
principe de la démocratie de débattre et
de faire des compromis si nécessaire
mais je crois que malheureusement Macron
a toujours pas envie d'aller dans cette
direction alors retournons à l'Assemblée
nationale si vous le voulez bien donc
parmi les autres sujets parliez le
prochain débat qui donc auront lieu vous
avez annoncé que vous déposerez une
proposition de loi avec votre collègue
Emeric Caron pour interdire la pratique
de la corrida en France alors
aujourd'hui c'est une exception dans la
loi donc de protéger au nom de la
tradition oui vous vous avez raison de
le présenter comme ça parce qu'en fait
dans la loi la maltraitance et la
cruauté envers les animaux et quelque
chose et c'est heureux déjà interdite
d'ailleurs que ce soit des actes cruels
euh en public ou dans la sphère privée
on ne peut pas impunément maltraiter les
animaux et ce qui est insoutenable dans
la situation actuelle c'est qu'en fait à
ce principe général qui est évidemment
un très bon principe il y a des
exceptions alors soit disant au nom de
la tradition mais bon ça se débat dans
quelle mesure est-ce que la corrida est
une tradition très ancrée dans notre
pays parce qu'en fait c'est quelque
chose qui a à peine plus d'un siècle et
qui concerne certaines régions très
délimité du pays et à ce titre là il y a
des exceptions et il y a une
autorisation d'avoir des des actes qui
sont cruels parce que malheureusement
bon bah dans les faits une corrida à la
fin c'est quand même ça qui se passe et
c'est la mise à mort du taureau dans des
conditions qui sont quand même
difficilement soutenables donc voilà moi
je pense
personnellement en tant que député la
question de la cause animale c'est
quelque chose auquel je suis je suis
sensible et je pense que voilà sur ces
sujets là il faut réussir à avancer j'ai
conscience que c'est parfois pas simple
de faire bouger les lignes qu'il y a
parfois des secteurs de la société qui
n'aiment pas qu'on remette en cause leur
pratique aussi cruelle qu'elle soit mais
je pense que là dessus faut avoir un peu
de à des moments faut avoir des
principes il faut les défendre on peut
pas se dire en tant que responsable
politique parce que si je fais tel
proposition il y a tel secteur de la
société qui va s'indigner bon bah vaut
mieux pas la faire et rester discret
voilà moi sur ce genre de sujet je
préfère assumer mais mes principes et
donc effectivement avec mon collègue
député de la nuque Emeric Caron et
d'autres on est plusieurs à déposer
cette proposition de loi voilà on la
dépose et on espère maintenant qu'on a
déposé la proposition de loi on espère
qu'elle sera mis à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale mais là pour le
coup ça dépend plus de nous c'est le
bureau de l'Assemblée nationale qui
décide et donc on a notamment besoin que
les macronistes prennent cette cette
décision mais du coup on parlait tout à
l'heure de dialogue de compromis etc
peut-être que sur ce sujet là on peut
espérer qu'on est des députés
macronistes qui se rendent compte que
c'est un sujet qui est peut-être
transverse entre les différents partis
politiques et que ça pourrait être
intéressant qu'ils acceptent de le
mettre à l'ordre du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale final pour que cette loi soit
adoptée j'espère en 2020 donc selon le
journal La Dépêche la corrida en France
avait un chiffre d'affaires estimé de 40
millions d'euros sans compter les
recettes année elles comptaient entre 1
et 1,5 millions de visiteurs à Bayonne
un million à Nîmes 400000 à Arles 900000
à Dax 630 000 à Mont-de-Marsan c'est
tout un écosystème finalement de des
villes du sud de la France qui
s'écrouleraient avec cette interdiction
c'est pour ça que c'est un débat qui qui
Clive qu'est-ce que vous proposez au
monde de la tauromachie comme
reconversion attendez d'abord sur le
principe parce que ça rapporte de
l'argent on peut rien faire on peut pas
le remettre en cause
bah non moi ça c'est un raisonnement que
je peux pas que je peux pas entendre et
qui d'ailleurs dans l'histoire politique
c'est pas un raisonnement et un argument
qui qui est nouveau vous savez que il y
a deux siècles dans ce pays quand on a
aboli l'esclavage le principal argument
de ceux qui s'opposaient à l'abolition
de l'esclavage c'est de dire que vous
comprenez économiquement ça va être un
problème pour les colonies s'il y a plus
cette main d'oeuvre cette main d'oeuvre
gratuite donc il y a un moment il y a
des progrès dans la société qu'il faut
faire où il faut être capable de dire
c'est pas parce que ça rapporte de
l'argent qu'il faut l'accepter ad vitam
eternam et moi je suis convaincu que
notamment tous les territoires toutes
les régions où se pratiquent aujourd'hui
la corrida du point de vue de
l'attractivité touristique c'est des
territoires qui ont plein de choses
formidables à proposer et que on n'est
pas obligé de tuer des taureaux pour que
il y ait des touristes qui viennent voir
une belle région avec un beau patrimoine
culturel et j'ai pas d'inquiétude sur le
fait de possibilité de reconversion
toujours dans le tourisme dans la
culture locale de tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui vivent de près ou de loin
avec la corrida toujours avec William
Martinet député LFI des Yvelines on va
passer à la deuxième partie la partie
locale de l'hebdopolitique
donc on passe maintenant à l'actualité
locale dans les Yvelines nous sommes
toujours donc avec William Martinez le
député à la fille des Yvelines nouveau
visage de l'Assemblée nationale
à Rambouillet dans le département la
situation de l'hôpital c'est dégradé la
majoration des heures supplémentaires
liées au covid n'ont pas été payées vous
avez accompagné les syndicats lors d'une
discussion avec la direction la députée
Renaissance Aurore Bergé vous a répondu
sur Twitter qu'en 5 ans c'était 32
millions d'euros qui avaient été investi
à le dans l'hôpital de Rambouillet alors
où est passé l'argent alors d'abord dire
moi j'ai vraiment été scandalisé par la
situation de l'hôpital de Rambouillet
donc comme vous le disiez je me suis
déplacé à l'hôpital à l'appel des
personnels et des syndicats qui ont fait
une heure de débrayage parce que vous
savez que quand on est personnel
soignant c'est compliqué de vraiment
faire grève parce que si on s'arrête
vraiment complètement de travailler
évidemment ça pose des problèmes pour
pour les personnes qui sont accueillies
à l'hôpital donc c'est c'est pas
toujours facile pour eux d'exprimer leur
mécontentement et là ils l'ont fait par
là je disais une de débrayage où ils se
sont rassemblés devant devant l'hôpital
pour prendre la parole et voilà donc
j'étais présent avec avec eux et ensuite
ils ont été reçus par la direction de
l'hôpital pour parler de la
revendication et moi je les ai
accompagnés enfin j'ai accompagné la
délégation au syndicale pour discuter
avec la direction de l'hôpital bon ce
que j'ai vu je disais moi ma absolument
révolté parce qu'on a à la fois le
problème de fond de l'hôpital public
c'est-à-dire
sous-financement pénurie de personnel
aussi une logique managériale de plus en
plus importante avec des objectifs
chiffrés et si on tient pas les
objectifs chiffrés on n'a pas les
financements derrière donc ce qui
transforme complètement le métier fait
perdre le sens de ce métier que d'être
que d'être soignant on est à la fois
confronté à tout à tout ça ce qui crée
du coup une véritable difficulté une
souffrance pour les personnels qui sont
qui sont à l'hôpital parce qu'ils sont
mal payés peu reconnus et ils ont des
conditions de travail difficiles
qui crée un cercle vicieux parce que
quand vous avez des personnels qui sont
en souffrance et bah ils partent quand
ils peuvent ou en tout cas c'est
difficile de recruter donc ça veut dire
qu'on se retrouve avec une pénurie de
personnel pas seulement parce qu'on n'a
pas assez d'argent pour recruter mais
même sur les postes ouverts il y a
personne qui veut venir parce que c'est
trop dur de travailler à l'hôpital donc
du coup ça fait que les conditions de
travail se détériorent encore plus parce
que voilà je disais cercle vicieux on
n'est pas assez nombreux du coup on
n'arrive pas à recruter du coup les
conditions de travail sont encore plus
dures etc etc donc on est à la fois
confrontés à ça mais qui pour le coup
est pas limité à l'hôpital de
Rambouillet c'est dans tout le pays
qu'on est confronté à ça vous savez que
cet été on a eu un Rambouillet mais
comme ailleurs des services d'urgence
qui l'ont dû qui ont dû fermer voilà là
aussi je parlais tout à l'heure des
étudiants de se dire comment ça se fait
que dans la sixième puissance économique
mondiale il y a des étudiants qui est
pas de quoi se payer à manger bah là je
peux le redire comment se fait-il que
dans la sixième puissance économique
mondiale qui est des services d'urgence
qui ferment l'été parce qu'on n'a pas
les moyens les personnels c'est quand
même fou là les médecins
urgentistes à Rambouillet nous expliquer
que du fait des fermetures plusieurs
jours du service d'urgence à Rambouillet
c'est du coup le service médical
d'urgence de Versailles qui prenait le
relais donc ça veut dire et du coup de
quoi on parle concrètement ça veut dire
vous avez un accident de voiture grave
dans le sud des Yvelines bah l'ambulance
elle partira pas de remouiller elle
partira de Versailles avec ce que c'est
implique dans alors du coup le langage
technique vous savez on dit perte de
chance voilà c'est comme ça que les
médecins parlent mais en fait perte de
chance ça veut dire le risque de décéder
notamment qui est qui est plus important
on en est on en est là donc vraiment une
situation qui est qui est terrible c'est
pour ça que quand madame berger parle de
ces 34 millions investis moi je je sais
pas quel calcul elle a fait en fait elle
veut rien dire ce chiffre je ne sais pas
de quoi elle parle sur quelle durée pour
faire quoi voilà moi ce que j'ai
constaté juste c'est le sous-financement
de l'hôpital mais vous avez raison de
parler de Madame berger parce que c'est
sa circonscription normalement l'hôpital
de de Rambouillet c'est quand même fou
qu'il y ait besoin d'un député nups de
la 11e circonscription des Yvelines qui
traversent le département pour aller à
digital et pour être à l'écoute des
difficultés qu'on rencontre les
personnels soignants donc j'espère que
que Madame berger va un peu plus se
préoccuper de la situation de son
hôpital à Rambouillet toujours la
mosquée a été détruite par un incendie
criminel en quelques heures
l'association des musulmans de
Rambouillet avait déjà récolté 13000
euros près de 5000 contributeurs alors
là sécurité c'est aussi un enjeu majeur
la première ministre annoncé 8500
policiers supplémentaires en 5 ans sur
le territoire national est-ce que pour
vous plus de policiers c'est plus de
sécurité alors d'abord permettez-moi un
mot sur le ce qui s'est passé à la
mosquée il nous faut encore plus
d'informations il faut que l'enquête de
police aille jusqu'au bout mais on a
quand même des indications assez claires
sur le fait que c'est un incendie
criminel qui a eu qui a eu lieu parce
qu'on a des témoins qui ont vu des
personnes fuir avec des bidons d'essence
dans la main enfin c'est quand même
assez clair donc il y a de la il y a de
la malveillance et il y a une attaque du
coup claire contre la communauté
musulmane donc dans ces moments là il
faut le dire avec beaucoup de force dans
la République française dans la
République laïque il est inacceptable
que des concitoyens du fait de la
religion soient attaqué soit menacée
comme ça a été le cas là moi je suis
très heureux de la réaction pour le coup
qui ont eu à la fois le préfet des
Yvelines qui ont eu aussi tous les élus
et compris madame berger je pense que ça
c'est une belle chose aussi qu'on soit
capable dans ce genre de moment de
montrer l'unité nationale face à ces
événements donc moi je me joins à ça
j'ai et je soutiens la communauté
musulmane de Rambouillet qui a été qui a
été attaquée dans ces dans ces
événements et je dis vraiment faisons
front républicain tous ensemble après
sur le sujet de la sécurité qui est plus
qui est plus large parce que
heureusement la question de se limite
pas à ce genre à ce genre d'événement il
faut il y a une question de moyens de
police c'est c'est clair il y a une
question de répartition des moyens de
police sur le territoire parce que moi
qui suis élu d'une circonscription
notamment avec des villes et des
quartiers qui sont très populaires on
constate bien comment paradoxalement ce
sont les territoires
[Musique]